[Music]
all right so two people were rescued
after falling in a chocolate tank at
pennsylvania's eminem mars fact that
sounds like some charlie into chocolate
factory [ __ ] man remember that [ __ ]
fat boy that fell into the river if two
people fell it just reminds me of those
like fights in 90s movies where you fall
over the rail
i know exactly what you're talking about
the fugitive and [ __ ]
that [ __ ] always happens they even just
did that like a couple years ago in like
one of the bomb movies oh my god it's
perfect i'm thinking i'm thinking of the
joker now from michael keaton with jack
nicholson where he falls into the
[ __ ] tank they always follow the vat
of something nefariously
hey chocolate though i would be down to
fall in a pool of chocolate once oh
absolutely
i paid to do that but they died right
yeah they're dead now
no no no they they actually they
actually got turned into chocolate uh
superheroes
did people eat
and once one super villain yeah one
supervisor yeah
yeah
i thought you said they pulled them out
oh no they later killed themselves over
the embarrassment oh no they're not dead
but they're in a hospital oh
no you'll never get the facts they have
to be chipped away maybe that's why or
they have you
ended up with a thin candy shell
or do you think that they just take them
out and then they're like man it's too
bad these two i think they're i think
that
it's game over for them and they just
leave them in a room and then they're
staying they're like frozen like this
and starts
like gargoyles that's the beginning of
the [ __ ] movie
that is good oh they get wrapped in like
[ __ ] foil and [ __ ] colored foil oh do
you think it's [ __ ] boiling hot
though
oh yeah that has to be yeah because i
don't know but you know when you like
dip a [ __ ] strawberry into like
fondue chocolate it's warm it's warm
it's not it's not burning hot though
because then the chocolate will get
[ __ ] up
yeah it can't be a certain burning
chocolate it has to be a very specific
temperature it can't be bubbly well i'm
hoping the temperature is not
life-threatening temperature
the worst part of the story is that
they've you know you guys are probably
imagining they're they're swimming in
like a big tall tank right yeah but it's
like waist height no way so it's like
[ __ ] horse diving from the 1920s
oh so that's why they still got
hospitalized because like they oh didn't
have to do with the chocolate so then
they fell and then they just hit the
bottom of the table why was it that tall
if there was only this much the great
[ __ ] wine stopper oh
you're going like that yeah like in the
movies yeah swims the edge and pull
yourself out so does that mean they had
to dump all the chocolate because it was
contaminated that's the worst part they
said they're gonna still use all the
chocolate okay good because i don't like
it when people waste food they just run
it through the chocolate filter one more
time yeah yeah yeah yeah
just do another chocolate funnel
filter it because i'm against wasting
food
big time even if there's like human in
it
well i mean
they just fell in it were they kids
they didn't like child labor to be fair
i'm one of those guys that when there's
like a hair in my like food i'm like oh
this is gross i pull it out and i throw
it like and you finish it yeah but when
it's like multiple that's when i go
that's too much it depends on how long
if it's like short and squiggly yeah
they were
yeah two two double check not me say
what their genders or ages are is long
just that they're contest winners
oh they're contest winners yeah that's
all it says so they got the golden
ticket dude people are the gym the
winners
they're legit
living out the movie the charlotte
charlie and the chocolate factory movie
you wanna hear what happened to the guy
in the [ __ ] glass elevator what
happened to him
he's dead dude he's [ __ ] dead whoa
they launched it and they're like oh
[ __ ] we probably shouldn't figure out
where they think but that's supposed to
be charlie he's supposed to own the
place how come there's no like live leak
video of this i feel like i know there's
no cctv footage the best articles are
always the shortest and they have the
least amount of cool images did you guys
see the mr beast made a [ __ ] charlie
chocolate factory
i did yes in fact i'm going to click off
of this video and go watch that right
now
over here plugging mr beast
like he needs more plugs
[ __ ] guy here's a call to action guys
i saw i scrolled over this is how i
watch youtube now i just scroll my
scroller over the [ __ ] thumbnail and
it does slides and you can kind of see
it and then you're like that was dope
and then you just move on to the next
video why do i do that too why can't i
just click on the [ __ ] video oh you
know that's that's that's that's
that's a funny thing to do it's like i
wonder if when mtv was was edgy they
would do that they go hey you know
what's real cool vh1
[Laughter]
dude [ __ ] it we're actually
yeah well didn't he doesn't he do [ __ ]
because of like trees and nature and
like helping the world i don't know dude
but this is like
we're in a toilet huh
oh my god there's the chocolate river
cake
there's a chocolate toilet it's either a
cake or not oh you got to eat the toilet
it's a real toilet what's an ad what is
this i feel like you could tell in real
life if it was real look at that there's
a darker toilet that's for sure a cake
have you seen the show where they do is
it cake or not yes and it looks
completely fake we're at the [ __ ]
chocolate factory god damn it they're in
it that is the chocolate fact dude they
got [ __ ] gordon ramsay oh [ __ ]
there's [ __ ] gordon ramsay there yeah
let's go because it's mr beast this
guy's good i didn't get to that part
joe you're just like you're just sitting
there on the thumbnail and you're
watching
like yeah
yeah joe you're so strange i love it
and then i like to read the captions
because you know the video just just
goes yeah like automatically and then i
see if i want to watch it oh he dropped
it he dropped the dish oh they're making
like uh scrambled eggs oh oh scrambled
eggs
having a chocolate factory would be
pretty [ __ ] lit no request all right
do you guys wanna do you guys want to go
in on a chocolate factory yeah but with
what money joe yeah with what money
drink we're all wrecked we got wrecked
[ __ ]
that's true
well i'll i'll get back there and let me
stick my cardano and we'll talk about it
all right let me just take my thirty
five dollars a card
because if i were to make a candy
factory you guys wanted i i have access
to a chocolate factory for real yeah
only dark chocolate though i don't like
nothing else oh yeah didn't your friend
make it big with like freaking my buddy
has a shop in pasadena it's it's bean to
bar so he gets the beans and he makes
the chocolate from the whole thing yeah
i like it it's called car artisan
chocolate what
car artisan yeah he
but is it one of those like bougie-ass
chocolate like it's just chocolate you
go in it's all like
it looks like the kind that you drink
coffee with no it's not i want that
cheap ass chocolate the kid that the
things that give kids [ __ ] cavities i
want but is it like a cool looking
you know operation yeah yeah or is it
like a bunch of stainless steel and then
there's
the shop is pretty fancy it's pretty
nice we're trying to see oompa loompas
you know what i mean yeah
we'll get some opa [ __ ] white
overalls and green hair i paint myself
[ __ ] orange dude i actually don't
really like chocolate do you does anyone
not like chocolate you just don't like
it at all yeah this is because i had a
traumatic incident with chocolate one
time what was so traumatic about
chocolate you [ __ ] this is my
birthday and we were in australia for
that tour were you there no it was the
year before you guys went down yeah nick
wizard and so it was my birthday it was
october right and we're at this club and
then they're like oh it's happy birthday
surprise here's a cake and it's a
chocolate penis-shaped cake
with candles in it and then i was like
all right let me blow out the candles
and then they [ __ ] like
my face and that's why you don't like
chocolate and i was like kind of on
stuff and and i was drunk so what were
you immediately uh i was i don't know it
was probably laced with something it was
it was supposed to be uh
mdma but it was like something else for
sure so then you just saw yourself
getting slammed in a big black dick yeah
i was in the zone bam yeah it was funny
not that i think back at it but then
he's so high it's it's it's a real big
black dick yeah and so i like struggle i
was like mad i got super angry and then
after that i calmed down and i realized
like oh [ __ ] they were just [ __ ]
around and why am i tripping and then
after that was it lit though was the
candles lit uh no no no no i was it was
like i just like that this happened to
you and instead of like you don't like
chocolate now but dicks are fine
i watch bbc porn all the time
that whole thing made me just go like
[ __ ] i hate chocolate dude like i don't
want to eat it well i'm glad that you
don't hate black dick yeah no that's
because that'd be way worse that's
that's discrimination bro
it was dumbo
wow
it was annual i think it was dumbo and i
think charles was the one that held me
he held my arms bro those are good
homies dude do you realize how [ __ ]
funny that is though it is funny because
that's your head getting pushed down to
a like what looks like a penis so that's
a little bit but did you like chocolate
before that incident yes
how sad
they ruined chocolate for the candles
stabbed in the face or something no it
didn't i just can't if it makes you feel
better i've also been given a penis cake
for a birthday and they have also caked
me with it and i for some reason love
chocolate and penis more
no way
now i shoved my
yeah it was just that combination with
that moment and the shock factor do you
think you're high that explains
everything you think if you weren't on
anything like what would your reaction
have been i wasn't like oh it's a
[ __ ] joke
[Laughter]
and they're like where'd the cake go i
probably would have just laughed and
like just ate it off my face or whatever
but
yeah that was something that like could
have sworn there was a cake earlier
do it when people bring it up to you are
you like oh guys i had a traumatic
chocolate incident
[Laughter]
when you go to ghirardelli's are you
like where's the trigger warning
[Music]
you